>> Tyra: PREVIOUSLY
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THE HARSH REALITY
OF THE MODELING WORLD
OVERWHELMED CATIE
AND SPARKED A RIVALRY
BETWEEN YOANNA AND CAMILLE...
Camille: IF I HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY TO YOU,
I WILL SAY IT TO YOUR FACE.
>> Tyra: WHILE SARA FACED
HER FATHER'S DISAPPROVAL.
Sara: HE CONSIDERS MODELING
PROSTITUTION.
>> Tyra: AND IN
THE LAST ELIMINATION,
XIOMARA WAS SENT HOME.
SEVEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Catie: AT LAST JUDGING,
WHEN IT WAS YOU
AND XIOMARA UP THERE,
DID YOU THINK
SHE WAS GOING HOME,
OR YOU WERE GOING HOME?
Camille: I'M NOT--
I WASN'T GOING HOME.
I WAS JUST CHILLING.
I WASN'T NERVOUS.
Tyra: CAMILLE,
CONGRATULATIONS.
Catie: CAMILLE IS
AN INCREDIBLY STRONG WOMAN.
SHE HAS NO VULNERABILITY
AND SHOWS NO EMOTIONS,
HAPPY NOR SAD.
SHE'S ALWAYS JUST MEDIUM.
BE HONEST--
WHAT ONE DID YOU LIKE BETTER,
LONG HAIR OR SHORT HAIR?
Camille: I THINK
THAT WITH YOUR SHORT HAIR,
YOU CAN DO SOME
FUNKY THINGS WITH IT.
YOU JUST HAVE TO PLAY WITH IT.
Catie: WELL,
WHAT MY PROBLEM IS
IS I'M TRYING TO CHANGE WHO I AM
FOR THE JUDGES TO LIKE ME.
I THINK IT REALLY SUCKS.
Camille: SALUD!
SALUD.
Sara: SALUD.
Mercedes: OH,
MINE'S WAY BIGGER.
April: MINE'S WAY BIGGER.
Mercedes: NO, MINE ACTUALLY
GOES OVER MY STOMACH.
April: THAT'S A BELLY!
Mercedes: MY BELLY
SURPASSES YOURS.
April: SIX-PACK--GONE.
Mercedes: IT LOOKS
LIKE I'M 2 POUNDS.
Catie: EW!
CAMILLE PUTS KETCHUP
ON HER PICKLES.
April: THAT'S OKAY.
DON'T SAY, "EW!"
WHEN PEOPLE DO STUFF.
Yoanna: WE DON'T GO, "EW!"
WHEN YOU'RE EATING
YOUR HAMBURGERS.
Catie: I WAS JUST SAYING--
I DIDN'T MEAN IT IN A RUDE WAY.
I WAS JUST SAYING, YOU KNOW...
NO, BUT YOU GUYS
DO IT TO ME A LOT.
Mercedes: CATIE--
SHE'S GETTING
TOO SENSITIVE FOR ME.
IT'S JUST, LIKE, "SHUT UP!
SHUT UP! SHUT UP! SHUT UP!"
Catie: IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A JOKE.
Yoanna: GUYS,
THERE'S TYRA MAIL!
"THE WORLD IS FULL OF COLOR,
BUT SOMETIMES IT'S SEEN BEST
IN BLACK AND WHITE."
WE HAVE TO PREPARE FOR A
BLACK-AND-WHITE PHOTO SHOOT,
WHICH I THOUGHT IS SO GREAT.
CLASSIC! GET READY.
Shandi: RIGHT NOW!
RIGHT NOW!
Camille: I WOKE UP
THIS MORNING, AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON, BUT MY MOUTH
WAS LIKE SUPER, SUPER-SWOLLEN,
AND IT HURT.
IT'S JUST GETTING WORSE,
LIKE IT'S JUST GETTING TIGHTER.
LIKE,
IT'S HARDER FOR ME TO TALK,
'CAUSE IT'S IN THE CORNERS.
April: IS IT THIS WHOLE AREA,
OR JUST ISOLATED?
Camille: EVERYTHING.
Mercedes: CAMILLE
IS HAVING FAT LIPS,
AND SHE HAS, LIKE, AN ALLERGIC
REACTION TO SOMETHING.
SHE'S PROBABLY
FEELING SELF-CONSCIOUS.
Camille: BUT IT JUST, LIKE--
I DON'T HAVE BIG LIPS,
BUT IT'S JUST BIGGER.
I FEEL IT.
AND YOU'RE GONNA SEE IT
IN THE PICTURES.
Jay: GOOD MORNING.
TODAY IS A BIT OF A CHALLENGE,
'CAUSE WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
ARE BEAUTY SHOTS.
THE CAMERA IS RIGHT IN HERE,
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT EMOTING
WITH YOUR EYES.
TODAY'S PHOTOGRAPHER
IS BILL HEUBERGER, AND HE IS
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
HE'S EVEN SHOT TYRA BANKS.
Bill: IT'S WHAT'S INSIDE
THAT'S GONNA MAKE YOU PRETTY,
AND IF WE CAN CAPTURE THAT,
THEN WE'RE DOING WELL.
Jay: NOW I KNOW, CAMILLE,
YOU HAD AN ISSUE
'CAUSE YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE HAVING
AN ALLERGIC REACTION TODAY.
Camille: I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE ORDER IS,
BUT IF I COULD JUST, LIKE,
HANG OUT FOR A MINUTE,
MAYBE THE SWELLING AND STUFF
WILL GO DOWN, YOU KNOW?
Jay: WE CAN HAVE YOU
GO LAST TODAY.
Camille: OKAY.
Jay: SO LET'S GET GOING.
TECHNICALLY, A BEAUTY SHOOT IS
THE MOST DIFFICULT SHOOT TO DO.
IF YOU'RE NOT CONFIDENT,
IT'LL DEFINITELY READ
IN THE FINAL PHOTOGRAPH.
SO I THINK THE GIRLS TODAY,
IT'S KIND OF, LIKE,
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE FOR THEM.
Mercedes: THE PHOTOGRAPHER
KEPT GOING LIKE THIS...
(making clicking sounds)
LIKE, WHEN HE TOOK THE PICTURE.
HE KIND OF THREW ME OFF,
'CAUSE I STARTED SMILING,
AND IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE,
LIKE, SERIOUS AND SENSUAL.
Bill: (clicking)
April: SEE, I WANT TO CONVEY,
LIKE, A TONE, ESPECIALLY 'CAUSE
I NEED ALL THE OPPORTUNITIES
TO CONVEY SOME KIND
OF PERSONALITY THAT I CAN,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE, IF THEY SEE IT
IN A PHOTOGRAPH.
THEY HURT MY FEELINGS
SO MUCH YESTERDAY.
Mercedes: OH, THEY DID?
April: SOMEHOW THE JUDGES,
LIKE, DON'T LIKE ME, YOU KNOW?
Mercedes: OH, GOD.
April: LINGERING THAT MORNING
WAS THE COMMENT THAT,
"YOU HAD THE BEST PICTURE,
BUT THE JUDGES DON'T LIKE YOU."
Tyra: WHEN YOU TALK,
AND HOW YOU'RE MOVING YOUR HANDS
SO LIKE THIS,
IT'S NOT A LIKEABLE, WARM PERSON
THAT I REALLY WANT
TO GET TO KNOW BETTER,
AND I KNOW THAT'S INSIDE OF YOU,
AND I WANT THEM TO SEE
THAT BEAUTIFUL PART OF YOU.
Mercedes: YOUR THING JUST
DIDN'T PARTICULARLY GO WELL,
BUT THEY DIDN'T
TOTALLY REAM YOU EITHER.
April: I KNOW.
I'M SO SENSITIVE. I KNOW.
Mercedes: YOU ARE.
IT'S WHAT THEY REMEMBER.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
April: IT'S PERSONALITY, TOO.
Mercedes: BUT YOU HAVE
A PERSONALITY.
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU'RE A DRONE.
APRIL--I LOVE HER,
BUT SHE'S GONNA DIE
OF A HEART ATTACK
BEFORE SHE HITS 27,
BECAUSE SHE JUST PUTS
SO MUCH STRESS ON, LIKE,
THE LITTLE THINGS
AND DOESN'T LISTEN
TO THE POSITIVE THINGS.
Bill: OPEN YOUR EYES.
April: MY BIGGEST FEAR IS
THAT I WILL LEAVE
THIS COMPETITION AND BE TOLD,
"YOU KNOW WHAT, APRIL?
YOU GAVE US
FLAWLESS PHOTOGRAPHS,
BUT YOU DIDN'T STEP IT UP
A NOTCH AND BRING YOU OUT,
'CAUSE TO ME, THAT'S ALMOST LIKE
IMPLYING THAT I WAS AFRAID
TO DO THAT, AND I'M NOT AFRAID.
Catie: I'M GONNA LOOK BEST
WHEN I FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH WHO I'M BEING.
SO I'M GONNA GO EXACTLY BACK
TO MY PLAIN JANE LOOK AND BE ME.
THEY CAN CRITICIZE ME
EVERY WEEK IF THEY WANT TO,
BUT AT LEAST I'LL BE
COMFORTABLE.
Camille: MY MOUTH WAS, LIKE,
SUPER, SUPER SWOLLEN
AND IT HURT.
Jay: ACTUALLY,
IT'S NOT THAT BAD.
WE CAN TAKE IT DOWN.
SOMETIMES, YOU KNOW, AS MODELS,
YOU NEED TO SHOW UP
IN WHATEVER THE CONDITIONS.
YOU JUST GOTTA GO.
YOU KNOW, THAT KIND OF THING.
Camille: JAY TOLD ME THAT
WHEN I'M IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
I HAVE TO PRETEND LIKE I DON'T
HAVE THIS PROBLEM RIGHT NOW.
Jay: GIVE IT TO ME
IN YOUR EYES.
GIVE IT TO ME IN YOUR ENERGY.
OKAY?
ALL RIGHT, GOOD. LET'S GO.
Bill: JUST LOOK
RIGHT AT THE CAMERA.
NICE AND RELAXED.
Jay: JUST ALWAYS GIVE ME,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF PRETTY EYE,
SOFT EXPRESSION.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
OTHERWISE, IT LOOKS
A LITTLE HARD.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW HOW
TO TURN IT ON AND OFF,
NO MATTER HOW TIRED YOU ARE,
NO MATTER HOW MUCH PAIN
YOU'RE IN.
YOU JUST HAVE TO DO IT.
I THINK CAMILLE GAVE IT
A GOOD SHOT.
DID CAMILLE GIVE 100%?
I DON'T THINK SO.
Bill: BINGO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Camille: I WANNA SEE
THAT THING, 'CAUSE I THINK
I DID REALLY WELL.
Jay: HEY, GIRLS,
THIS IS KYLE HAGLER,
A MANAGER OVER AT IMG.
YOU KNOW, TYRA'S WITH IMG.
Mercedes: THIS IS HUGE,
BECAUSE HE'S GONNA BE MANAGING
THE WINNER.
Kyle: IN THIS FIELD
THAT IS EVER-SO-CHANGING,
YOU'RE SEEING A LOT MORE
ACTRESSES
ON THE COVERS OF MAGAZINES AS
OPPOSED TO MODELS.
THE MODEL/ACTRESS--
SHE'S LIKE A DOUBLE THREAT,
BECAUSE SHE'S ABLE TO PROJECT
A FEELING.
SO TODAY YOU GUYS ARE GOING OFF
TO AN ACTING CLASS.
Yoanna: COOL.
Sara: I'M NERVOUS
ABOUT THE ACTING CLASS.
A LOT OF US HAVE NEVER GONE
ONSTAGE BEFORE.
Kyle: IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT YOU GUYS ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT THE TWO WORLDS WORK
SIDE BY SIDE.
April: I LOVE ACTING CLASS.
Camille: MY MOUTH RIGHT NOW
IS, LIKE...
Mercedes: IT'S NOT THAT BAD,
ACTUALLY.
LET ME SEE.
Camille: I CAN STILL FEEL IT.
Mercedes: I JUST CAN'T
REMEMBER HOW BIG YOUR LIPS WERE
TO BEGIN WITH.
Yoanna: CAMILLE IS LIKE
DRAMA, DRAMA, DRAMA, DRAMA.
HER LIPS WERE PUFFED UP,
SO SHE NEEDED SOME MEDICINE,
I GUESS, TO BRING DOWN
THE SWELLING.
Camille: I DON'T WANNA
MISS OUT ON THE ACTIVITY
FOR THE DAY,
BUT MY HEALTH COMES FIRST.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
CAMILLE? IS SHE COMIN'?
Catie: HER WHOLE MOUTH
IS SWOLLEN AND, LIKE,
IT'S MOVING BACK HERE.
Tyra: OH,
SHE'S AT THE DOCTOR?
Catie: YEAH.
Tyra: OH, OKAY.
I HAVE A VERY SPECIAL PERSON
HERE.
SHE'S ONE
OF MY VERY BEST FRIENDS.
HER NAME IS TASHA SMITH-ARQESE.
SHE IS AN AMAZING ACTRESS.
THE TOP MODELS IN THE WORLD
KNOW HOW TO ACT.
Tasha: YOU NEED SOMETHING
GOING ON ON THE INSIDE
IN ORDER TO LOOK IN THAT CAMERA
AND MAKE PEOPLE WANT YOU
TO SELL THEIR PRODUCT.
Tyra: I'VE DONE EXERCISES
WITH TASHA WHERE I'M CRYIN'
AND SCREAMIN' AND DON'T KNOW
HOW SHE GOT THAT OUT OF ME.
THAT ONLY MAKES ME
A BETTER MODEL, AND IT MAKES ME
A BETTER ACTRESS.
Tasha: SO, TYRA?
Tyra: BYE, Y'ALL!
BYE, MISS TASHA.
Tasha: THANK YOU, SISTA!
MWAH!
BYE, YOU GUYS.
Tasha: AND NOW YOU'RE ALL
IN MY HANDS.
Sara: WHEN TYRA LEAVES,
IT'S A WHOLE OTHER BALL GAME.
SHE'S LIKE,
"OKAY, WE'RE GONNA GET DIRTY."
Tasha: WHAT MAKES US
REALLY GOOD ACTORS
IS THAT WE'RE ABLE TO LOCATE
EACH INDIVIDUAL EMOTIONAL THING
AND UTILIZE IT AS A TOOL.
SO TODAY WHAT I WANNA REALLY
TRY TO WORK ON IS BEING OPEN
AND BEING HONEST.
I'M JUST GONNA GIVE YOU GUYS
THIS PIECE OF PAPER, OKAY?
AND LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT
REJECTION, BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
SOME OF YOU ARE GONNA HAVE
TO DEAL WITH--REJECTION.
YOU KNOW HOW IT FEELS?
HOW MANY OF YOU HAVE EVER HAD
A BOYFRIEND THAT BROKE UP
WITH YOU?
A DADDY THAT LEFT YOU?
IMAGINE THAT IS
A "DEAR JOHN" LETTER
FROM WHOEVER THAT PERSON IS
THAT YOU FELT REJECTED YOU
AND LEFT YOU.
LOOK AT IT.
YOU SEE THE EMOTIONS
THAT'S COMING UP?
Sara: IT'S, LIKE, WEIRD
BECAUSE YOU'RE LOOKIN' AT
A BLANK PIECE OF PAPER,
BUT IT HAS SO MUCH ON IT.
♪♪♪
April: EMOTIONS, TO ME,
ARE UNCONTROLLABLE.
WHEN I OPEN MYSELF UP TO THEM,
THERE ARE TEARS IMMEDIATELY,
AND IT'S, LIKE... (sighs)
Tasha: LOOK AT IT.
NOW I WANT YOU TO RIP
THAT PIECE OF PAPER UP
IN LITTLE TEENY PIECES.
RIP IT UP! RIP IT UP! RIP IT UP!
STOP!
NOW ALL OF YOU RIGHT NOW
ARE HURTING.
ALL OF YOU RIGHT NOW
MAY BE FEELING ANGER,
HURT, PAIN.
DON'T FORGET WHAT YOU'RE FEELING
RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO USE THIS.
IF YOU'RE WORKING TO TRY
TO ACCOMPLISH A CAREER
AS AN ACTOR-- HELLO.
Camille: HI. HOW ARE YOU?
Tasha: SO WE HAVE
A NEW PERSON COMING IN.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
Camille: CAMILLE.
Tasha: HI, CAMILLE.
Camille: I'M SLOWLY LOOKING
AT EVERYONE'S FACES,
REALIZING THAT PEOPLE ARE KIND
OF SAD AND CRYING AND QUIET.
SO I'M JUST LIKE,
OH... MY... GOD.
Tasha: WHAT IS IT
THAT YOU'RE FEELING RIGHT NOW?
LIKE, WHAT'S THE THING THAT
MADE YOU BREAK DOWN AND CRY?
Sara: MY DAD.
MY FATHER JUST HAS THIS MINDSET
THAT MODELING IS NOT THE JOB
FOR A DAUGHTER.
Tasha: I NEED YOU
TO LOOK AT HER
AND SAY TO YOUR FATHER
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE WANTED
TO SAY ABOUT HOW HE'S HURT YOU.
I WANT YOU TO REPEAT EVERYTHING
THAT SHE SAYS QUIETLY, OKAY?
BEGIN TO TALK.
Sara: I'M DOING THIS,
BUT IF YOU DISOWN ME--
I'M GONNA BE A MODEL.
Mercedes: I'M GONNA BE
A MODEL.
Sara: YOU CAN HATE ME.
Mercedes: YOU CAN DO
WHATEVER YOU WANNA DO...
Sara: IT'S KIND OF LIKE
AN OUT-OF-BODY EXPERIENCE,
AND I'M FEELING JUST THIS ENERGY
AROUND US.
Shandi: I DON'T KNOW ANYONE
IN MY FAMILY BECAUSE OF YOU.
I HATE YOU.
Catie: AND THERE WERE TIMES
I DID NOT WANNA LIVE BECAUSE
OF YOUR (bleep) FACE.
April: YOUR (bleep) FACE.
Mercedes: I DIDN'T THINK
WE WERE GONNA GET THIS HEAVY
THE FIRST DAY,
BUT THIS WHOLE LESSON
WAS TO TEACH YOU
TO BE HONEST AND VULNERABLE.
April: I'M SO TIRED...
Catie: I'M SO TIRED.
April: OF BEING BRAVE...
Catie: OF BEING BRAVE...
April: OR FOR...
Women: (crying)
Sara: WE'RE LETTING
JUST ALL OF THESE, YOU KNOW,
EMOTIONS IN OUR PERSONAL LIVES
OUT.
Mercedes: (sobbing)
Sara: (sobbing)
AND CAMILLE'S THE ONLY ONE
THAT'S NOT AFFECTED
BY ANY OF THIS.
Camille: MOM,
YOU'RE MY STRENGTH.
Yoanna: MOM,
Camille: I LOVE YOU.
Yoanna: I LOVE YOU.
Tasha: STOP.
I WANT YOU TO DEAL WITH
THE THINGS THAT ARE NOT SO EASY.
LET'S CHANGE IT.
ARE YOU ANGRY AT ANYBODY?
Camille: I'M NOT ANGRY
AT ANYONE.
Tasha: NO?
Camille: I THINK...
Yoanna: (scoffs)
Tasha: YOU?
THAT'S INTERESTING.
LOOK IN HER EYES.
AND OBVIOUSLY,
YOU DID SOMETHING TO HER, TOO.
SO WE MAY AS WELL GET IT ALL OUT
RIGHT NOW.
Yoanna: OKAY, LET'S GO.
Tasha: OKAY,
SO YOU HAVE TO REPEAT HER.
Camille: IN THE HOUSE,
I FELT LIKE YOU WERE
TARNISHING MY CHARACTER.
IT HURT BECAUSE...
Yoanna: IT HURT BECAUSE...
Tasha: BE HONEST, CAMILLE.
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY
TO JUST BE HONEST.
Camille: IT HURT BECAUSE
Yoanna: BECAUSE...
Camille: I'M IN
A NEW ENVIRONMENT
WITH NEW PEOPLE,
AND I'D REALLY LIKE FOR EVERYONE
TO GET ALONG.
Tasha: COME ON!
YOU'RE SUCKING RIGHT NOW!
Yoanna: I WAS ALMOST WISHING
THAT SHE WOULD HAVE IT OUT
WITH ME AND JUST SAY WHATEVER
SHE FELT REPRESSED,
AND THAT WAY, WE COULD JUST
KIND OF HATCHET IT
AND GET ON AND BE ADULTS.
Tasha: I JUST FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE STILL ON THE SURFACE.
THERE'S STUFF INSIDE YOUR HEART
THAT'S GOING ON THAT YOU JUST
REFUSE TO LET OUT.
Camille: I'M TRYING HERE.
I'M TRYING!
Tasha: I JUST--I DO.
I FEEL LIKE YOU JUST WANNA HAVE
THIS PERFECT MASK ON.
Camille: IT HAS TO DO
WITH ME, INSIDE OF ME.
Tasha: BUT GOD BLESS YOU
IN YOUR CAREER,
BUT YOU'RE JUST BORING.
Camille: I'M SITTING UP THERE
WITH YOANNA, 'CAUSE I'M COMING
INTO THIS NEW SITUATION NOW,
MISSED THE FIRST HALF
OF THE ACTING EXERCISE,
MY MOUTH IS THE SIZE
OF A FRICKIN' WATERMELON,
AND I WAS JUST LIKE...
OKAY.
Tasha: TOMORROW YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A TEST.
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT THIS SCENE.
MAKE IT REAL
AND MAKE IT EFFECTIVE
THE WAY YOU AFFECTED EACH OTHER.
THE ONLY ONE YOU PROBABLY WASN'T
AFFECTED BY WAS CAMILLE.
Camille: I KNOW
IT'S A COMPETITION,
AND WE HAVE TO DO THIS
IN ORDER TO WIN,
AND SO WE HAVE TO GET
INTO THIS ACTING ROLE.
IT'S JUST GONNA BE
VERY DIFFICULT.
THAT JUST MIGHT BE MY DOWNFALL.
Sara: THE ACTING DAY
WRAPS UP WITH EVERYBODY JUST
REALLY EMOTIONALLY DRAINED.
Camille: I DIDN'T SEEM
EMOTIONAL?
April: NOT REALLY.
Sara: MNH-MNH.
Camille: LIKE, I'VE NEVER
SEEN MY GRANDMOTHER CRY.
I'VE NEVER SEEN MY MOTHER CRY.
I'VE NEVER SEEN
MY FATHER CRY.
April: MM-HMM.
I THINK THAT YOU HAVE A WALL
WITHIN YOURSELF THAT YOU'RE NOT
LETTING YOURSELF FEEL.
THERE'S A REASON YOU'RE NOT
TAPPING INTO YOUR OWN EMOTIONS,
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANNA
GO THERE.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA GO THERE
WITH SOMEBODY ELSE?
IT'S JUST, IT'S NOT HAPPENING
FOR YOU.
Yoanna: YOU WANNA MEMORIZE?
Shandi: I JUST KEEP SAYING,
LIKE, A CERTAIN PART OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AND OVER.
Yoanna: TASHA,
OUR ACTING COACH,
GIVES US A SCRIPT THAT WE HAVE
TO LEARN AND MEMORIZE.
Sara: IT SAYS IN THE SCRIPT,
LADIES, "THEY EMBRACE AND ENGAGE
IN A PASSIONATE KISS."
Shandi: SO THAT'S, UM...
Mercedes: I HOPE I GO FIRST
SO I DON'T HAVE TO TASTE
ANY OF YOU OTHER HOS.
Shandi: EW!
(laughter)
Shandi: THIS MAKES NO SENSE.
Yoanna: THE SCRIPT
WAS KINDA CHEESY,
BUT I GUESS A LOT
OF ACTING SCENES ARE.
Shandi: WHY WOULD YOU
SAY THAT?
NO PERSON WOULD SAY THAT.
YOU WOULDN'T SAY...
(dramatic voice) "I REMEMBER
YOUR FUNERAL
LIKE IT WAS YESTERDAY."
(normal voice) YOU WOULD SAY,
"I REMEMBER
THE MILITARY FUNERAL
LIKE IT WAS YESTERDAY."
Catie: THE SCRIPT SEEMS
VERY SOAP OPERA, LIKE...
(dramatic voice)
"OH, COLIN, BLEHH, BLEHH."
April: OOH, I WANNA PLAY
COLIN FOR SOME PEOPLE.
(deep dramatic voice)
"DO YOU LOVE HIM?"
Mercedes: SEEMS LIKE
TEN WEEKS SINCE--I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVEN'T EVEN READ THAT YET.
April: "IS IT DIFFICULT
FOR YOU?"
Mercedes: APRIL--
SHE'S THE ONLY ONE IN THE HOUSE
THAT GOT THAT SCRIPT AND WAS,
LIKE, STUDYING FOREVER.
WHEN SHE SEES SOMETHING,
SHE DOES IT PERFECTLY.
SHE'S LIKE A MACHINE.
April: I REALLY
UNDERSTAND NOW HOW
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO USE TODAY
TO WORK THROUGH THIS SCRIPT.
I NEED TO JUST COME IN
THROUGH THE DOOR SWINGING
WITH PERSONALITY AND EMOTION.
Catie: HERE,
I'LL PRACTICE WITH YOU.
April: (sighs) I'M NOT
PRACTICING, LIKE, THE LINES.
I'M TRYING TO PRACTICE
THE EMOTIONS.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING--
I JUST NEED TO, LIKE,
TAKE MYSELF THERE, YOU KNOW?
I PRETTY MUCH MEMORIZED IT
ALREADY.
Catie: REALLY?
April: YEAH.
Catie: EVEN THIS
WHOLE SPIEL ABOUT REMEMBERING
THE MILITARY FUNERAL?
April: MM-HMM.
Catie: OH, GOOD GRAVY.
I HAVEN'T.
Tasha: HI, GORGEOUS LADIES.
Women: HELLO.
Tasha: SO TODAY IS TEST DAY.
I GET TO PICK AND CHOOSE
WHO'S GONNA WIN
A FABULOUS SHOPPING SPREE TODAY
AT ONE OF NEW YORK'S
FINEST JEWELERS.
YOU'RE GOING TO READ
THIS MATERIAL
WITH ONE OF THE STARS
OF "AS THE WORLD TURNS"--
MR. MARK COLLIER!
HI, MARK.
Yoanna: WHEN MARK HAD
WALKED OUT, I COULD SEE
THIS LITTLE GIDDY GRIN
ON SHANDI'S FACE,
AND SHE WAS EXCITED TO, LIKE,
PROCEED WITH THE SCENE.
Tasha: ANYTHING YOU WANNA SAY
TO THE GIRLS?
Mark: JUST REACT AND BE AS
HONEST IN THE SCENE AS YOU CAN.
Shandi: THE SCENE IS ABOUT...
April: A WOMAN NAMED LAURA...
Catie: WHOSE HUSBAND
WAS IN THE MILITARY.
April: SHE THINKS HE'S DEAD.
Shandi: SO SHE MOVES ON.
Catie: AND HE COMES BACK.
Tasha: ACTION.
April: I DIDN'T BELIEVE IT
WHEN THEY TOLD ME,
BUT IT'S TRUE.
Sara: I DIDN'T BELIEVE IT
WHEN THEY TOLD ME,
BUT IT'S TRUE.
Catie: IT'S TRUE.
YOU'RE ALIVE.
Yoanna: YOU KNOW,
WHEN THEY TOLD ME THAT
YOUR PLANE WENT DOWN
IN THE JUNGLE AND THAT
THERE WERE NO SURVIVORS...
Sara: WHEN THEY GAVE ME
THAT FLAG THEY DRAPED
OVER YOUR COFFIN...
Mercedes: I PUT IT
UNDER MY PILLOW...
April: AND I CRIED MYSELF
TO SLEEP EVERY NIGHT
FOR SIX MONTHS.
Mark: APRIL'S DOING
A GREAT JOB.
I BELIEVED IN HER EYES.
SHE WAS BEING TRUTHFUL
TO THE SITUATION.
Shandi: AND I CRIED MYSELF
TO SLEEP EVERY NIGHT
FOR SIX MONTHS.
Mark: SHANDI IS SHOWING
AN OPENNESS.
I SAW IT IN HER EYES.
THERE WAS THIS CONNECTION
THAT SHE HAD THAT A LOT OF
OTHER PEOPLE DIDN'T HAVE.
Catie: WHEN THEY TOLD ME
YOUR PLANE WENT DOWN
IN THE JUNGLE...
AND THERE WERE NO SURVIVORS,
I DIDN'T SHED A TEAR.
Mark: CATIE--
SHE'S SHOWING YOU EVERYTHING
BUT NOT FEELING ANYTHING,
WHICH MAKES IT
NOT VERY BELIEVABLE.
Mark: (suppresses chuckle)
Catie: AND THEN I--
AND THEN I MET A MAN.
I'M HALF-ASSING IT.
HOW THE CRAP
CAN I TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY?
I'M NOT FEELING THIS GUY.
AND HE MADE ME REALIZE
I COULD LIVE AGAIN.
Sara: AND I CRIED MYSELF
TO SLEEP FOR SIX MONTHS.
Mercedes: CRIED MYSELF
Camille: I CRIED, COLIN,
NOT FOR ONE, NOT FOR TWO,
BUT I CRIED FOR SIX MONTHS.
Mark: CAMILLE HAS TAKEN IT
UPON HERSELF TO CHANGE
A LOT OF THE LINES,
WHICH JUST REALLY
SHOULDN'T HAPPEN.
Camille: YOU KNOW ME--
LAURA, STRONG AND PROUD,
THE ONE THAT YOU LOVED
AND RESPECTED.
I'M APPROACHING THE SCENE
WITH THE FACT THAT I'M
GONNA BE ME, WHICH IS UNIQUE.
(stilted voice) I DIDN'T
BELIEVE IT.
IT'S TRUE. YOU ARE ALIVE.
I FOCUSED MY ENERGY
INTO SCULPTING.
I EVEN GAVE SOME AWAY
TO CHARITY.
Yoanna: AT THE END,
THERE'S SUPPOSED TO BE
A PASSIONATE KISS.
April: I LOVE YOU.
I ALWAYS HAVE,
AND I ALWAYS WILL.
♪♪♪
Shandi: THIS IS
THE END OF THE SCENE--
PASSIONATELY KISS.
TO ME, PASSIONATE IS TONGUE,
SO THERE YOU GO.
Yoanna: WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
WE'VE BEEN STUCK
WITH 12 GIRLS.
IT WAS TIME
FOR SOME TESTOSTERONE.
Catie: WE HAVE TO KISS
THIS PERSON.
ECCH!
UGH!
Tasha: YOU COULD'VE
KISSED HIM BETTER THAN THAT.
Catie: I CAN'T,
I HAVE A BOYFRIEND.
SORRY.
Tasha: SO WHAT?
THIS IS ABOUT WINNING.
YOU HAVE TO STAY COMMITTED
IN THE SCENE.
IF YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
YOUR BOYFRIEND,
ONLY HALF OF YOUR HEART'S
GONNA BE IN THIS SCENE.
Catie: MM, OKAY.
Camille: I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
WHY DID YOU HAVE TO
LEAVE ME?
WHY DID YOU HAVE TO LEAVE ME,
BABY?
(sniffling)
Tasha: BEFORE I SAY ANYTHING,
MARK, I'LL GIVE YOU THE HONORS
TO SAY SOMETHING FIRST.
Mark: YOU DO SOMETHING
FOR DAVID MAMET
OR SOMEBODY LIKE THAT,
YOU CHANGE THEIR WORDS,
YOU WON'T HAVE THAT JOB ANYMORE,
I PROMISE YOU THAT.
Tasha: I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'VE LEARNED
SOMETHING BETWEEN TODAY
AND YESTERDAY.
I DIDN'T BELIEVE ANYTHING
YOU DID UP THERE.
NOTHING.
I THOUGHT IT WAS HORRIBLE.
Camille: I THOUGHT
I DID WELL.
I RESPECT HER,
BUT SHE HAS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
DIFFERENT PEOPLE ARE DIFFERENT.
Tasha: (sighs)
POOR CAMILLE.
SHE'S CLUELESS.
(horn honks)
Tasha: CAN WE HAVE
ALL OF OUR LADIES COME OUT
ONTO THE STAGE, PLEASE?
DID YOU SEE HOW IMPORTANT
YESTERDAY WAS
TO REALLY ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL
OF TODAY?
IT WAS REALLY INTERESTING.
DID YOU LEARN SOMETHING?
CAMILLE, YOU WERE NOT AFFECTED,
AND YOU REFUSED TO BE AFFECTED.
I SAY GET AFFECTED.
GET AFFECTED.
CATIE, YOU KNOW HOW HARD
YOU WORKED
AND HOW HARD YOU DIDN'T.
SOMETIMES YOU MAY GIVE UP
BEFORE IT'S OVER,
AND IF YOU DO THAT,
YOU AUTOMATICALLY LOSE.
Catie: MM-HMM.
Mark: APRIL AND SHANDI,
TO ME, WERE THE BEST.
Tasha: YOU GUYS WERE
THE BEST, THE TOP OF THE LINE,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
THERE CAN ONLY BE ONE WINNER,
AND THE WINNER IS...
Mark: APRIL.
Tasha: YOU ALLOWED
ALL YOUR INNER EMOTIONS
TO COME OUT.
YOU DIDN'T TRY TO HOLD BACK.
April: THE POSITIVE FEEDBACK
FELT REALLY GOOD TO ME
BECAUSE ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
I THINK I'VE BEEN HAVING
IS LETTING THE REAL ME
COME THROUGH.
Tasha: THE PRIZE...
IS A FABULOUS SHOPPING SPREE
AT ONE OF THE TOP JEWELRY STORES
IN NEW YORK CITY.
YOU GET TO PICK SOMEBODY
TO GO WITH.
April: CATIE.
CATIE IS 18 YEARS OLD.
SHE'S--SHE'S STILL A TEENAGER,
AND HONESTLY, WHEN I'M WITH HER,
I FEEL LIKE I'M 18, TOO,
SO I WANTED TO BRING HER
WITH ME.
Catie: I'M SO EXCITED.
WE'RE GONNA GET HER
SOME GOOD JEWELRY,
GET HER SOME BLING.
♪♪♪
Camille: TODAY WAS, UM,
A BAD DAY ACCORDING TO,
YOU KNOW, THE PEOPLE
I'M GETTING CRITIQUED BY
BECAUSE THEY SAY THAT
I'M KIND OF, LIKE, UNATTACHED,
LIKE, I'M NOT, LIKE, EMOTIONAL.
Catie: SHOULD I SAY HI
TO HIM?
HOW COME YOU'VE NEVER CRIED
IN FRONT OF CAMILLE?
SHE'S VERY EMOTIONALLY DETACHED.
Camille's dad: (chuckles)
Catie: I JUST WANNA SEE
THAT THIS GIRL'S HUMAN.
Camille's dad: Okay, then.
Catie: BECAUSE US GIRLS ARE
♪ EMOTIONAL ♪♪
SHOW ME SOME EMOTION!
Mercedes: WHEN YOU GET
ALL THIS CRITICISM
FROM THE JUDGES AND STUFF,
HOW DO YOU HANDLE THAT?
Camille: I THINK OF IT
AS BEING POSITIVE.
LIKE, I DON'T THINK OF IT--
Mercedes: IT'S NOT REALLY
POSITIVE INFORMATION.
THE ONLY WAY FOR HER
TO HANDLE CRITICISM
IS TO BE HARD, TOUGH
AND DOMINATE THE SITUATION.
Camille: SUPPOSEDLY,
I'M THE WORST OUT OF, LIKE,
EVERYONE ELSE.
IT'S OKAY, 'CAUSE IF I WANT
TO DO THE ACTING THING,
I WILL DO THE ACTING THING.
Mercedes: SO PLEASE VOTE
FOR CAMILLE.
Camille: THAT'S IT.
Mercedes: SHE'S RUNNING
FOR OFFICE.
SHE WANTS THAT CONTROL 24/7,
AND SHE JUST FEELS LIKE
IF SHE LOSES THAT CONTROL,
SHE WON'T BE ABLE TO WIN.
Camille: (scoffs)
I'M GOOD, SO...
April: COME ON, DARLIN'!
Catie: GOD, THEY PICKED
THE PERFECT PRIZE FOR THIS DAY.
April: I'M SO EXCITED.
H. STERN.
Catie: AAH!
April: HI!
I FEEL LIKE A LITTLE GIRL
IN A CANDY STORE
WHO JUST GETS TO PICK
WHAT SHE WANTS.
I LIKE THOSE EARRINGS,
THAT NECKLACE.
WHAT A FABULOUS NIGHT
FROM START TO FINISH
TO BE ABLE TO PERFORM ONSTAGE
FOR THE FIRST TIME,
AND THEN TO HAVE IT TOPPED OFF
WITH THIS.
PINCH ME, PINCH ME.
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
THESE ARE PERFECT FOR ME. YEAH.
Catie: YEAH, OKAY. YAY!
April: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TAKE CARE.
Woman: BYE.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT. TAKE CARE.
Yoanna: TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW WE'LL SEE WHO
WILL FIGHT THE BEST FIGHT
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
BE READY TO LEAVE
AT 6 IN THE MORNING."
Camille: WHAT?
Catie: SHE'S GONNA FIGHT US.
Yoanna: ARE WE GONNA BOX?
Mercedes: I DON'T WANNA
KICK TYRA'S BUTT.
Catie: WE'LL SEE TOMORROW.
WE'LL FIND OUT.
(alarm clock beeping)
Catie: YUCK.
THIS IS HEALTHY OATMEAL.
Sara: IS IT THAT BAD?
Catie: DISGUSTING.
Sara: MMM, IT'S GOOD.
Catie: ECCH.
♪♪♪
April: THE TYRA MAIL
WAS PRETTY VAGUE,
SO WE JUST ARE READY
FOR ANYTHING.
♪♪♪
Jay: GOOD MORNING.
TODAY YOU'RE DOING
A TELEVISION COMMERCIAL
FOR ROLLITOS CHIPS.
Sara: OH, MY GOD.
Jay: YOU GIRLS HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE TO WORK WITH
A TALENTED DIRECTOR AND OWNER
OF MOST REMARKABLE FILMS,
JAMES GAY.
JAMES, COME OUT AND SAY HEY.
James: WE HAVE A SCRIPT
TO GET THROUGH, WHICH IS
A LITTLE DIFFERENT FOR YOU GUYS.
WE HAVE A LOT TO DO,
SO THERE'S NO TIME
TO BE NERVOUS.
Jay: ACTUALLY, TODAY WE'RE
AT THE DARYL ROTH THEATRE,
HOME OF THE SHOW "DE LA GUARDA."
SO WE'RE GONNA DO SOMETHING
A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
Yoanna: OH, MY GOD! AAH!
♪♪♪
Catie: WE'RE DOING THAT?
Jay: ESSENTIALLY,
THE IDEA IS YOU GIRLS
ARE IN A ROUGH AND TUMBLE
AERIAL CATFIGHT
FIGHTING TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
BUT YOU'RE FIGHTING LIKE
THERE'S ONLY ONE BAG
OF CHIPS LEFT.
(laughter)
Catie: I'M REALLY JUST
FOCUSING ON HOW ANGRY I AM
THAT I'M PUT
IN THIS SITUATION AGAIN.
BEFORE WE DID
THE SUSPENDING SHOOT,
I HAD A NERVOUS BREAKDOWN.
MY ULTIMATE FEAR IN LIFE
IS FALLING TO MY DEATH.
(sobbing)
I'M SHAKING.
SET ME ON FIRE, THAT'S COOL.
JUST DON'T
PUT ME UP IN THE AIR.
Sara: CATIE, YOU HAVE
TO SHUT UP ABOUT THIS STUFF,
BECAUSE I'M AFRAID OF HEIGHTS.
OH, MY GOD.
I HAVE THREE KNEE OPERATIONS,
AND I'M SCARED TO FALL
ON MY KNEE, BUT, HEY,
I'M NOT THINKING ABOUT IT
AND START BREAKING OUT
AND CRYING.
Jay: SHOOTING FILM...
Catie: YEAH, I KNOW.
Jay: TAKES SO MUCH MORE TIME
THAN SHOOTING JUST A PHOTOGRAPH.
Catie: YEAH.
Jay: AND I WAS THINKING,
"OH, MY GOD.
IF CATIE STARTS DYING..."
I JUST NEED YOU TO DO THIS.
Catie: THIS IS
SO, SO FRUSTRATING.
IT'S JUST SO MUCH PRESSURE.
♪ THE FUTURE IS NOW ♪
♪♪♪
James: WE ARE DOING
A COMMERCIAL TODAY.
THIS IS A TWO-FOLD CONCEPT.
THESE GIRLS HAVE TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO
LINES AND TO DO STUNTS.
WE HAVE A LOT TO DO.
OHH!
THAT'S WHAT I WANT.
Camille: THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT DAY FOR ME
BECAUSE YESTERDAY A COMMENT
WAS MADE TOWARDS ME
THAT I WOULDN'T WIN, YOU KNOW,
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
BECAUSE I CAN'T ACT
AND I'M NOT SHOWING MY EMOTIONS.
WELL, HERE, I DON'T HAVE TO CRY.
SO, UM, I THINK THAT
I'LL DO VERY WELL ON THIS.
Woman: GO, GIRL.
YOU'RE GONNA BE LIKE
FLYING TRAPEZE GIRL.
Catie: MM-HMM.
Woman: UH-HUH.
James: AND ACTION.
♪♪♪
Shandi: IT REALLY LOOKS
LIKE A MOVIE,
JUST THIS SURREAL KIND OF WORLD
THAT WE'RE IN,
AND IT'S JUST AWESOME.
♪♪♪
James: APRIL, THAT'S PERFECT.
Jay: APRIL'S GREAT.
SHE LOOKS GREAT.
James: APRIL IS REALLY GAME.
SHE'S WAY ON TOP OF IT.
SHE STAYS FOCUSED AND SHARP
THE ENTIRE TIME.
Jay: CAMILLE,
LOOK AT THE INTENT
ON APRIL'S FACE.
James: CAMILLE WAS
A LOT OF FUN TO WORK WITH.
SHE'S ATHLETIC.
SHE TOOK DIRECTION VERY WELL.
James: GRIT YOUR TEETH,
CAMILLE.
CAMILLE WAS VERY GOOD.
OKAY, CATIE, ARE WE READY?
♪♪♪
Catie: I PRETTY MUCH ASSUME
I'M GOING TO FALL TO MY DEATH,
WHICH IS A VERY SCARY THOUGHT.
WE'RE OKAY, WE'RE OKAY.
Jay: CATIE GETS NERVOUS
WITH EVERYTHING.
I REALLY DON'T EVEN HAVE
A GREAT SHOT ON CATIE.
I'VE GOT A SO-SO SHOT.
James: YOU CAN COME DOWN.
Sara: CATIE
IS STILL SO YOUNG,
AND SHE'S REALLY EMOTIONAL
ABOUT THINGS.
Catie: Y'ALL ARE TRYING
TO GIVE ME A NERVOUS BREAKDOWN.
Sara: HER BEHAVIOR
TOWARDS EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW--
PEOPLE ARE GONNA GET FED UP
WITH IT.
IT'S GONNA CATCH UP WITH YOU
IN THE END.
April: WE'RE GETTING READY
TO DO DIALOGUE.
THIS IS, LIKE,
COMBINING MODELING WITH ACTING
AND THE KIND OF CHARACTER
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO PLAY.
James: THREE, TWO, ONE.
April: IN THE END,
THERE'LL ONLY BE ONE CHOICE
FOR AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Camille: THAT LOOKS GOOD.
THAT'S VERY GOOD.
James: ARE YOU ROLLING?
Man: YEP.
James: AND THREE, TWO, ONE.
Camille: IN THE END,
THERE'LL ONLY BE ONE CHOICE
FOR AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
James: OKAY.
UM, LET'S BREAK IT UP.
Camille: (British accent)
FOR AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
James: CAMILLE NEEDS TO WORK
ON HER DICTION.
ACCENT WAS A LITTLE BIT
OF AN ISSUE.
Camille: (Spanish accent)
YOU'VE GOTTA FIGHT LIKE THERE'S
ONLY ONE BAG OF ROLLITOS LEFT.
Shandi: Sí, SEÑOR.
Mercedes: I THOUGHT
SHE WAS JAMAICAN.
WHERE THE HELL DID THE CUBAN
COME FROM?
I MEAN, I'M MORE CUBAN THAN HER,
HONEY, BUT I'M NOT EVEN LATIN.
Camille: WHO SAID
I COULDN'T ACT, HUH?
I THINK I DID PRETTY WELL
CONSIDERING
SOMEONE TOLD ME THAT
I COULDN'T ACT.
YOU KNOW, HEY,
I THINK I DID VERY WELL TODAY.
MM-HMM.
Catie: IN THE END,
THERE WILL ONLY BE ONE CHOICE
FOR AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
James: CATIE WAS
A LITTLE BIT FLAT
IN HER DELIVERY.
Catie: SO YOU GOTTA BE TOUGH.
James: AND SHE WAS
A LITTLE BIT MONOTONE.
Sara: IN THE END...
Yoanna: THERE WILL ONLY BE
ONE CHOICE.
Mercedes: UNO, BABY.
Sara: FOR
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Shandi: SO YOU GOTTA BE
TOUGH.
Mercedes: HEY,
A GIRL'S GOTTA DO
WHAT A GIRL'S GOTTA DO.
Jay: TOUGH SUPERHERO,
NOT TOUGH BRONX.
James: YEAH.
Mercedes: I'M FROM JERSEY.
Shandi: YOU GOTTA WATCH
YOUR BACK.
Sara: (roars)
Catie: (roars)
Mercedes: (roars)
Yoanna: (roars)
James: GOOD. THANK YOU.
Jay: GREAT, YOANNA.
♪♪♪
Shandi: "TOMORROW YOU WILL
MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY SIX OF YOU WILL CONTINUE."
Sara: ONE OF US
IS GOING HOME.
Catie: SWEET.
MORE ROOM IN THE REFRIGERATOR.
Mercedes: I HAVE NO IDEA
WHO'S GOING HOME.
IS IT YOANNA?
IS IT CAMILLE
BECAUSE OF HER ATTITUDE?
IT COULD BE CATIE, 'CAUSE SHE
SEEMS, LIKE, VERY IMMATURE.
Catie: (groans)
I HATE MY HAIR!
Mercedes: I KNOW
IT'S NOT APRIL.
APRIL'S GOT IT IN THE BAG.
April: RIGHT NOW
HONESTLY, I AM CONFIDENT
IN THE RECENT STUFF.
BUT I ALSO KNOW THE JUDGES--
THEY CONSIDER EVERYTHING.
Catie: THE COMPETITION
IS TIGHT.
NONE OF US CAN REALLY BE
REALLY CONFIDENT
ABOUT BEING HERE ANYMORE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
Women: HELLO.
Tyra: SO NOW IT'S TIME TO
MAKE OUR SIXTH CUT
TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
A CONTRACT WITH IMG MODELS,
A PHOTO SPREAD
IN "JANE" MAGAZINE
AND A COSMETICS CAMPAIGN
WITH SEPHORA.
ALL RIGHT, HERE'S OUR CRAZY,
OPINIONATED JUDGES--
MISS JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE FIRST SUPERMODELS
OF THE WORLD,
AND NEXT WE HAVE ERIC NICHOLSON,
SENIOR FASHION EDITOR
AT "JANE" MAGAZINE.
WE HAVE NIGEL BARKER, WHO IS
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
AND THIS WEEK'S GUEST JUDGE
IS MR. KYLE HAGLER,
WHO HAPPENS TO BE ONE OF MY
MANAGERS AT IMG MODELS.
NOW THIS WEEK YOU'LL BE
EVALUATED ON WHAT YOU LEARNED
ABOUT ACTING AS WELL AS
YOUR BLACK-AND-WHITE PHOTO.
AND THEN THE JUDGES
WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE'LL DETERMINE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
SHOULD BE ELIMINATED.
SO NOW LET'S SEE THE FINAL EDIT
OF THE COMMERCIAL
THAT YOU GUYS SHOT.
♪♪♪
Catie: IN THE END...
Sara: IN THE END...
Camille: THERE WILL ONLY BE
ONE CHOICE.
Yoanna: THE ONLY CHOICE.
Mercedes: UNO, BABY.
Shandi: JUST ONE...
April: FOR
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
Camille: SO YOU'VE
GOTTA BE TOUGH.
Catie: YOU GOTTA
WATCH YOUR BACK.
Mercedes: AND YOU GOTTA
FIGHT...
April: LIKE THERE'S JUST
ONE BAG OF ROLLITOS LEFT.
Women: (grunting)
Catie: THERE'LL ONLY BE
ONE CHOICE.
Yoanna: JUST ONE.
Camille: BUT DON'T WORRY.
Shandi: THERE'S PLENTY
OF ROLLITOS LEFT TO GO AROUND.
(cheers and laughter)
Tyra: AWESOME.
ALL RIGHT, NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND THEN THE JUDGES
WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE'LL DETERMINE WHICH ONE
OF YOU SHOULD BE ELIMINATED.
WE'VE RANDOMLY DRAWN NAMES,
AND, APRIL, YOU'RE FIRST.
SO THIS WEEK, THE ACTRESS,
MISS TASHA SMITH-ARQESE,
IS GONNA BE ADMINISTERING
YOUR TEST.
Tasha: TODAY YOU'RE GOING TO
BE TESTED ON HOW WELL
YOU CAN TAKE DIRECTION, APRIL.
I'LL BE GIVING YOU A LINE.
THE LINE IS,
"I'VE NEVER WANTED ANYTHING
MORE THAN THIS,
AND IF I DON'T GET IT,
I'M GOING TO DIE."
I NEED YOU TO MAKE ALL OF THEM
WANT YOU SEXUALLY.
THAT'S YOUR OBJECTIVE.
Tyra: THINK OF YOUR MAN.
PUT YOUR MAN'S FACE...
Janice: THAT'S FUNNY.
Tyra: ON OUR FACES.
April: I HAVE NEVER WANTED
ANYTHING...
Sara: MORE THAN THIS,
AND IF I DON'T GET IT,
I'M GONNA DIE.
Janice: OW!
Catie: AND IF I DON'T GET IT,
I'M GONNA DIE.
Kyle: I DIDN'T GET IT.
Camille: I'VE NEVER WANTED
ANYTHING MORE THAN THIS,
AND IF I DON'T GET IT,
I'M GOING TO DIE.
Kyle: IT'S LIKE
YOU'RE WALKING A RUNWAY.
Tyra: THAT'S WHAT
I WAS GOING TO SAY.
Kyle: BUT REALLY, IT WAS LIKE
A DRAG QUEEN RUNWAY IN HARLEM.
Janice: (laughing)
Tasha: I NEED YOU
TO MAKE THE PANEL LAUGH.
YOU HAVE TO SAY THAT LINE
WITH THAT INTENDED OBJECTIVE.
Shandi: I'VE NEVER WANTED
ANYTHING MORE IN THIS LIFE,
AND IF DON'T GET IT,
I'M GOING TO DIE!
Nigel: YOU ALMOST
MADE ME CRY INSTEAD OF LAUGH.
April: I HAVE NEVER WANTED
ANYTHING MORE THAN THIS...
Sara: AND IF I DON'T GET IT,
I'M GONNA DIE!
OH, MY GOD!
Janice: AAH!
Mercedes: I'VE NEVER WANTED,
LIKE, ANYTHING THAN THIS...
Catie: AND IF DON'T GET IT,
I'M GOING TO DIE.
Kyle: IT WASN'T FUNNY
AT ALL.
Yoanna: WELL, I'VE NEVER
WANTED ANYTHING MORE THAN THIS,
SO IF I DON'T GET IT,
I'M GONNA DIE.
Janice: CONVINCE ME
THAT YOU'RE FUNNY.
JUST ONCE. JUST CAN I--
CAN I SEE IT? AAH!
(laughter)
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, YOANNA.
YOU HAD A BLACK-AND-WHITE
PHOTO SHOOT
PRODUCED BY DAYLUX STUDIOS.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nigel: VERY PRETTY.
Janice: FABULOUS.
Kyle: BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
Nigel: YOU STILL NEED
TO WORK ON YOUR POSTURE
A LITTLE BIT, THOUGH.
I NOTICED THAT YOU GOT
ONE SHOULDER THAT'S HIGHER
THAN THE OTHER.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, SHANDI,
YOU HAD
A BLACK-AND-WHITE PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nigel: IT'S VERY
SORT OF BLAND TO ME.
Tyra: IT'S, LIKE,
KIND OF BLANK.
Janice: WATCH TYRA.
DO THE BLANK,
AND THEN PUT IT IN THE EYES.
WATCH HER. SHE CAN DO IT.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
HERE'S THE BLANK.
Janice: AND WATCH THIS.
GIVE IT TO ME, GIRL,
GIVE IT TO ME.
Tyra: HI, APRIL.
Janice: YOU'RE SMILING TODAY.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU SMILE.
WHAT HAPPENED THIS WEEK
THAT MADE YOU SO, YOU KNOW,
UNLEASHED YOUR SMILE?
April: ACTING
AND DOING THE COMMERCIAL.
Tyra: THE DIRECTOR
OF THE COMMERCIAL SAID THAT
YOU DID A GOOD LINE READING,
THAT YOU'RE VERY ATHLETIC,
BEAUTIFUL AND COMPOSED.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Eric: THERE'S
A SLIGHT ANDROGYNY,
WHICH IS NICE.
Tyra: YEAH, TAKE AWAY
THE PONYTAIL, AND SHE CAN BE
KIND OF A GUY.
IT'S KIND OF COOL.
Janice: A HOT GUY.
Tyra: AND THAT'S
A GREAT THING IN MODELING--
TO BE ABLE TO GO THAT OTHER WAY,
BECAUSE IT MAKES YOU
SO MUCH MORE VERSATILE.
ALL RIGHT, MERCEDES,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: OH, SO PRETTY.
I--I JUST--I'M CRAZY ABOUT
THE FULLNESS OF YOUR MOUTH,
THE DIGNIFIED LENGTH
OF YOUR NECK.
Kyle: I FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ME
AND ONLY ME, WHICH IS GREAT.
Mercedes: RIGHT.
Tyra: YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU LOOK LIKE TO ME?
YOU LOOK LIKE LAYLA ALI.
YOU KNOW,
LIKE HER BOXING PICTURES,
WHEN SHE'S LIKE,
"YEAH, THE FIGHT'S JUNE 27.
WATCH OUT, BITCH."
ALL RIGHT, CAMILLE,
THE DIRECTOR OF THE COMMERCIAL
SAID THAT YOU NEED WORK
WITH YOUR DICTION,
LIKE YOU WERE PUTTING ON
SOME TYPE OF ENGLISH ACCENT,
AND YOU WEREN'T INSTRUCTED
TO DO THAT.
SO YOU HAD
A BLACK-AND-WHITE PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nigel: IT SEEMS TO BE A BIT
LIKE AN ACTOR'S HEADSHOT.
Janice: I WISH
YOU HAD MORE NECK.
Tyra: THE REASON WHY
IT'S SO IMPORTANT AS A MODEL
TO REALLY SHOW
THE LENGTH OF YOUR NECK
IS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
SEPARATES YOU FROM, SAY,
AN ACTRESS IN A PICTURE.
MODELS TEND TO BE LONGER
AND MORE ELEGANT.
Camille: BUT I WAS ACTUALLY
LAYING DOWN ON THE GROUND, SO...
Tyra: YOU HAVE TO LEARN
HOW TO LAY DOWN ON THE GROUND
AND GET SOME NECK.
Nigel: SARA,
THE LOOK IN YOUR EYE
IS JUST VERY KIND OF... NICE.
YOU NEED TO HAVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE STRENGTH.
Kyle: YOU'RE SO MUCH MORE
BEAUTIFUL IN PERSON THAN
YOU ARE IN THAT PHOTOGRAPH,
AND YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
THAT PHOTOGRAPH
IS WHAT'S GONNA SELL YOU.
Eric: THE HALF SMILE
IS MAKING YOUR FACE
A LITTLE CROOKED.
Janice: LIKE,
"I HAVE A WISDOM TOOTH.
I HAVE, LIKE,
A BAD WISDOM TOOTH HERE."
Catie: HI.
Eric: HEY, CATIE.
Janice: OKAY,
JUST MESS IT UP.
Tyra: YEAH, THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU DID WITH THE HAIR.
Nigel: I'D LOVE TO SEE IT
OFF YOUR FACE.
Kyle: YEAH.
Janice: MESS IT UP.
THERE YOU GO.
Tyra: THAT'S SO MUCH BETTER.
Eric: I THINK YOU JUST NEED
TO BE STRONGER OR MORE INNOCENT.
THE REACTION THAT I GET
FROM YOU IS THIS SORT OF, LIKE,
SCARED GUPPY.
Nigel: IT LOOKS
VERY PETER PAN.
IT'S AMAZING HOW YOUNG.
YOU REALLY SEE
THAT YOU'RE 18 YEARS OLD THERE.
Janice: YOU LOOK 13.
REALLY, REALLY YOUNG,
LIKE CHILD PROSTITUTE.
Tyra: APRIL.
DAMN, THAT PICTURE'S PRETTY.
Eric: YEAH.
Nigel: I THINK ON THAT
TV COMMERCIAL THAT SHE SHOT,
SHE WAS ASTOUNDING.
Tyra: SARA.
Janice: SHE BLEW ME AWAY
IN THE ACTING BIT.
Eric: HER PHOTOGRAPH
THIS WEEK, THOUGH,
WAS NOT MY FAVORITE.
Tyra: SHANDI.
I THINK SHE'S THE ONLY GIRL
IN THE COMPETITION
THAT CAN DO REAL HIGH FASHION.
Janice: EVIL SHANDAI
TONIGHT--SHE LOOKS KIND OF LIKE
A PARIS HILTON WANNABE.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK.
Tyra: YOANNA.
Nigel: MY BIGGEST PROBLEM
IS HER BODY SHAPE, I THINK.
I WOULDN'T WANNA SEE HER
IN A SWIMSUIT.
Tyra: ISN'T IT WEIRD, LIKE,
WITH MODELS, IT'S LIKE A HOUSE?
Nigel: YEAH.
Tyra: YOU'RE LIKE,
DAMN, IT'S GORGEOUS,
BUT THE KITCHEN SUCKS.
EVERYBODY GOT SOMETHIN'.
I GOT SOMETHIN'.
MERCEDES HAS THAT PERSONALITY
THAT SHE'S FUN,
SHE'S VIVACIOUS.
SHE HAS A REALLY NICE ENERGY.
Janice: YOU KNOW,
SHE'S NOT HAVING MELTDOWNS,
YOU KNOW,
LIKE SOMEONE ELSE WE KNOW.
Tyra: CATIE?
Kyle: SHE DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH OOMPH.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE
THAT EXTRA SOMETHING THAT
REALLY PULLS ME INTO WANTING
TO KNOW MORE ABOUT CATIE.
Janice: I WANT SO MUCH MORE
OUT OF HER.
I'D LIKE HER TO SEE, LIKE,
TO PUT MAYBE CAR GREASE
IN HER HAIR
OR STREAK IT WITH SOME PINK.
Eric: SHE'S KIND OF
THE GIRL NEXT DOOR.
Janice: EW!
Eric: BUT I THINK
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
HAS TO BE, LIKE, THE GIRL, LIKE,
WAY OVER THERE.
Tyra: DOWN THE STREET
AND AROUND THE CORNER.
Eric: EXACTLY.
Tyra: CAMILLE.
Janice: SHE KNOWS EVERYTHING,
AND I DON'T WANT TO WORK WITH
SOMEONE WHO KNOWS EVERYTHING.
Tyra: I THINK
THE FASHION INDUSTRY
LOVES THE SWEET, SWEET GIRLS,
AND THEY LOVE THE DIVA BITCHES,
AND THEY DON'T LIKE
ANYTHING IN BETWEEN.
Nigel: I'M SORRY.
SHE REALLY IS RUDE
AND AGGRESSIVE.
Kyle: BUT I HAVE TO SAY
THAT SHE'S BEAUTIFUL,
AND I THINK HER DRIVE
COULD TAKE HER FAR.
Tyra: I JUST WANNA GO,
"CAMILLE, JUST GO... AAH!"
JUST LET GO!
THIS WHOLE CONTROL THING--
RELAX, GIRL.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
THERE ARE SEVEN OF YOU
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SIX PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE SIX PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE SIX OF YOU THAT
WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
APRIL.
KEEP ON DOING
WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
YOU REALLY OPENED UP TODAY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOANNA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
MERCEDES.
SHANDI.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: SARA.
ONE THING THAT'S FIGHTING
AGAINST YOU
IS THOSE BEDROOM SLEEPY EYES.
SOMETIMES THEY DON'T REALLY
PHOTOGRAPH THAT STRONGLY,
BUT IN THE ACTING CHALLENGE
TODAY, YOU ROCKED.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL CATIE AND CAMILLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE WOMAN THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
CATIE, SOMETIMES THE JUDGES
FEEL LIKE YOU ARE
A LITTLE BIT TOO COMMERCIAL,
A LITTLE BIT TOO SAFE.
I GAVE YOU A HAIRCUT THAT
I THOUGHT COULD EDGE YOU OUT,
MAKE YOU A LITTLE BIT MORE
HIGH FASHION,
BUT YOU MAY NOT BE
EMOTIONALLY READY
TO HANDLE THE DOG-EAT-DOG WORLD
OF MODELING.
CAMILLE...
THIS WEEK WITH
THE WHOLE ACTING EXPERIENCE,
YOU DIDN'T OPEN UP.
BUT BEING
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
IS ABOUT VULNERABILITY,
AND NOBODY WANTS
A COLD-ASS MODEL ON THE SET.
EVEN RIGHT NOW, CAMILLE,
HARD AS NAILS,
"I'M NOT GONNA LET ANYBODY
SEE ME SWEAT, 'CAUSE IF I HAVE
TO PACK MY BAGS,
THEY'LL KNOW I DIDN'T SHED
ANY TEARS FOR THEM.
I DIDN'T SHOW
ANY VULNERABILITY."
Tyra: CAMILLE,
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Camille: THANK YOU.
Tyra: THANKS, CATIE.
♪♪♪
Catie: I DON'T FEEL REJECTED.
I'M JUST
DISAPPOINTED IN MYSELF.
(sniffling)
THANKS, GUYS.
(sobbing)
Catie: I GOT MY ASS
KICKED OFF THE SHOW.
(bleep) CUT OFF ALL MY HAIR
FOR THIS (bleep).
OH, GREAT. CHIPPED MY NAIL.
(sighs)
GO BACK TO L.A.,
WORK MY ASS OFF.
GET TO THE TOP ON MY OWN.
♪♪♪
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
Shandi: I MISS MY BOYFRIEND.
I DO.
Tyra: SHANDI'S
LONG-DISTANCE RELATIONSHIP
IS TESTED.
Shandi: I AM REALLY PISSED!
Tyra: AND THE GIRLS TRY
TO WORK IT LIKE PROS
WHEN THEY TAKE THE STAGE
IN THE WORLD PREMIERE
MUSIC VIDEO OF MY FIRST SINGLE,
"SHAKE YA BODY."
♪♪♪
YOU SHUT UP.